[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este especial
informativo 2020 fue un año que con la
pandemia de kobe 19 rompió todos los
estándares aquí les hemos preparado un
resumen sobre la irrupción de una
pandemia que cambió el mundo hace
exactamente un año una serie de casos de
una neumonía desconocida ha empezado a
reportarse en la ciudad china de wuhan
las alarmas se prendieron en enero
cuando las autoridades daban cuenta de
un contagio descontrolado en la urbe de
11 millones de personas en tan sólo unos
meses el virus llegó a casi todo el
mundo y generó la cuarentena más grande
en la historia de la humanidad en el
siguiente reportaje especial les
mostraremos como un microorganismo hizo
que el mundo se detuviera
[Música]
carla
diciembre de 2019 gran parte del mundo
festeja la llegada de un nuevo año
[Aplausos]
mientras el mundo celebra esta ciudad en
el centro de china comienza a preocupar
a la comunidad científica e
internacional
los hospitales de buján empiezan a
recibir decenas de casos de un tipo de
neumonía extraña para los médicos
los primeros contagios son reportados a
la oms y las autoridades sanitarias de
china cierran el mercado mayorista de
mariscos después de que se descubriera
que los animales salvajes vendidos allí
pueden ser la fuente del virus
[Música]
a varios análisis china comunica que los
casos desconocidos de neumonía enojan no
son provocados por los virus del sars ni
del merz sino por uno nuevo de la
familia de los corona virus llamado en
un principio por la o ms 2019 n com
[Música]
el 11 de enero la comisión de salud
municipal de luján reporta la primera
muerte provocada por este coronavirus un
hombre de 61 años que había estado en el
mercado de mariscos pronto la comunidad
internacional empieza a girar su
atención hacia esta ciudad de 11
millones de habitantes
entiendo que las autoridades de china
continental que lidian con esta
enfermedad están en contacto con la
organización mundial de la salud así que
estoy segura de que continuarán haciendo
si este es un nuevo coronavirus y las
secuencias se han puesto a disposición
del público en plataformas en línea que
son accesibles para todos agua sarakhs
hasta dos días después de la primera
muerte las autoridades de tailandia y
japón reportan los primeros casos fuera
de china
[Música]
un nuevo reto para las autoridades
comienza la migración humana más grande
del mundo el año nuevo lunar chino
[Música]
pese a que los casos se multiplican
millones de ciudadanos viajan a sus
ciudades de origen
[Música]
el 21 de enero el virus cruza el océano
pacifico funcionarios en el estado de
washington confirman el primer caso en
eeuu un hombre de 30 años cerca de
desear
la buena noticia es que los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades y
nosotros estamos de acuerdo en que el
riesgo es bajo para los residentes del
estado de washington
tras este anuncio las alarmas se prenden
en el mundo y los aeropuertos comienzan
a tomar medidas
[Música]
luján anuncia que cerrará temporalmente
sus aeropuertos y estaciones de
ferrocarril tras las noticias de que el
número de muertos ha aumentado a 17 las
autoridades de china confirman al menos
547 casos
ah
pese a las restricciones globales el
virus aterriza en europa
el caso que fue hospitalizado en burdeos
y circuló en redes sociales es un caso
positivo confirmado de coronavirus el
paciente tiene 48 años acaba de regresar
de china donde pasó pocos días y estuvo
en la ciudad de wuhan el número de casos
globales continúa creciendo para el 25
de enero la cifra ya es de más de 1000
positivos y para el 27 el número de
muertos es de más de 100 ante el
incremento acelerado de casos rusia toma
medidas drásticas para frenar el avance
del virus
hoy le informamos a todos sobre las
medidas tomadas para cerrar la frontera
con china en el lejano esto están del
junio 30 días después de que comenzara
la crisis la organización mundial de la
salud hace un importante anuncio
andy clearing public health declaró una
emergencia de salud pública de
preocupación internacional por el brote
mundial del nuevo coronavirus show del
colon haber coronado a eros mientras el
mundo supera las 500 muertes dos escenas
de películas acuden al mundo
el crucero diamond princess que
transportaba a más de 3.700 personas he
puesto en cuarentena
y en la ciudad de epicentro del virus
hand se termina de construir un hospital
con capacidad para mil pacientes
fabricados en sólo 10 días
el 7 de febrero oli william un médico de
luján que fue blanco de la policía por
intentar alertar sobre el virus muere
contagiado
[Música]
pese a las disputas comerciales entre
eeuu y china el presidente trump elogia
la labor de beijing en el manejo de la
crisis
[Música]
anoche tuve una muy buena charla con el
presidente ché y hablamos principalmente
sobre el coronavirus están trabajando
muy duro y creo que están haciendo un
trabajo muy profesional
el 10 de febrero pese a que el
coronavirus ha cobrado la vida de más de
1000 personas en todo el mundo
el presidente de trump sorprende con una
polémica posición frente al virus
ahora el virus del que estamos hablando
sabes mucha gente piensa que
desaparecerá en abril con el calor
el 11 de febrero el director general de
la o ms nombra por primera vez una
palabra que se repetiría millones de
veces
winamp name ahora tenemos un nombre para
la enfermedad y es hobbit 19 hold it
nine en un turista chino que fue
diagnosticado con el virus muere en
francia convirtiéndose en la primera
persona en fallecer por el brote en
europa
la cifra de muertos por el coronavirus
asciende a más de 1500 y las autoridades
de egipto reportan un caso confirmando
así el primer positivo de áfrica
una segunda semana de febrero un rayo de
esperanza empieza a verse en china los
casos comienzan a disminuir y la crisis
parece haber terminado
entre febrero y marzo el virus ode se
expandió por europa en italia y españa-
se vivieron las escenas más duras con
hospitales y morgues colapsadas así
impactó la crisis al 'viejo continente'
la curva de contagio en china cede y la
vida en europa continúa con relativa
normalidad la alfombra roja se despliega
para el festival de cine de berlín el
carnaval de venecia colma las calles en
milán se juega un partido de fútbol
entre atalanta y el valencia
paralelamente en irán se llevan a cabo
elecciones legislativas
y todo el que está interesado en
defender los intereses nacionales debe
participar en las elecciones el virus se
esparce rápidamente entre el 20 y el 29
de febrero los casos en italia explotan
pasa de tener tres casos a superar los
1100 el país declara la alerta y en un
esfuerzo por contener el brote más
grande en europa autoridades de la
región de lombardía emiten una lista de
ciudades y pueblos que entran en un
bloqueo completo
otro país que preocupa es irán los casos
allí siguen el mismo ritmo que italia y
en pocos días superan los mismos incluso
el viceministro de salud
da positivo yo también me contagia de
coronavirus he tenido fiebre desde
anoche y mi examen preliminar resultó
positivo cerca de la medianoche me aislé
desde ese momento los fat crow mientras
la situación en italia irán se complica
en eeuu el presidente de trump continúa
minimizando la peligrosidad del virus
howitt debido a todos los que hemos
hecho el riesgo para el pueblo
estadounidense sigue siendo muy bajo
tres días después de estas declaraciones
estados unidos reporta la primera muerte
debida al virus
[Música]
el virus desembarca en latinoamérica
el paciente llegó a sintomático sin
fiebre o tos o gripe se quedó el viernes
y sábado y el domingo tuvo una reunión
con su familia para su regreso 2 el
lunes buscó una unidad médica
también se reportan la primera muerte es
lamentable tener que informarles que el
día de hoy ha fallecido
nuestra primera paciente que fue
diagnosticada por coronavirus en el
ecuador
y la economía empieza a sentir los
efectos de la crisis la reserva federal
de eeuu recorta las tasas de interés
pese al esfuerzo de las autoridades en
los días siguientes las principales
bolsas del mundo se hunde
[Música]
el 8 de marzo dos eventos paralelos
suceden en europa mientras en españa se
lleva a cabo una multitudinaria
celebración del 'día internacional de la
mujer' el primer ministro de italia
giuseppe conte firma un decreto que pone
en cuarentena parte del norte de italia
lo que afecta a unas 10 millones de
personas el documento se filtra horas
antes del anuncio oficial y miles de
ciudadanos empiezan a regresar a sus
hogares generalmente en el sur agravando
de esta manera la crisis
sólo un día después del anuncio la
situación se sale de control en italia
la restricción de cuarentena en el norte
se extiende a todo el país 60 millones
de personas deberán permanecer en sus
hogares noches de edad
ya no habrá una zona roja no habrá una
zona 1 o 2 de la península será italia
italia como zona protegida en italia y
una protesta el 11 de marzo la o&m se
hace un anuncio esperado voz alarm inglá
o ms ha estado evaluando este brote
permanentemente y estamos profundamente
preocupados tanto por los alarmantes
niveles de propagación y gravedad como
por los niveles de inacción por lo tanto
hemos determinado que el kobe 19 se
puede caracterizar como una panda raid
als pandemic tras el anuncio de la o ms
eeuu declara el estado de emergencia
nacional y francia comienza la batalla
contra el virus en nuestras fronteras
con países no europeos continuarán
cerradas hasta nuevo aviso
entonces desplegaremos todos los medios
necesarios para proteger a la población
de ceder a la protección la potencia
el mundo entra en confinamiento la
mayoría de los países imponen
restricciones de movilidad e implementan
cuarentenas generalizadas
imágenes de calles vacías en las
metrópolis más pobladas comienzan a ser
frecuentes
italia y españa- viven los días más
duros de la pandemia los hospitales se
saturan y las funerarias no dan abasto
en italia los camiones del ejército
tienen que ayudar a transportar los
cuerpos
el 24 de marzo de 2020 la llama olímpica
se apaga
propuse pues ponerlos por un año y el
presidente va que estuvo 100% de acuerdo
también acordamos que celebraremos los
juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos en el
verano de 2021 a más tardar hack para
send el primer ministro de reino unido
boris johnson se convierte en el primer
líder mundial en dar positivo los
superaremos y la forma en que vamos a
hacerlo es claro aplicando las medidas
de las que han escuchado tanto y entre
más efectivamente las cumplamos más
rápido nuestro país saldrá de la
pandemia y más rápido nos recuperaremos
respirar tras un mes de severa crisis en
europa los casos empiezan a disminuir en
los primeros días de abril
las imágenes de agradecimiento al
personal sanitario desde los balcones
inundan las redes sociales y la pandemia
cambia de epicentro
tras arrasar con algunos sistemas
sanitarios europeos el virus llega con
fuerza a eeuu el estado más afectado en
esta etapa de la pandemia es nueva york'
el virus devastó el corazón de la
economía internacional
la crisis en eeuu estalla y la pandemia
se politiza
mientras los líderes demócratas piden
cuarentenas estrictas para reducir el
número de casos los republicanos
encabezados por el presidente de trump
piden priorizar medidas que protejan la
economía
no vamos a destruir nuestro país tenemos
que regresar porque sabes en cierto
punto perderás más gente de esta manera
con todos los problemas causados que con
lo que estamos haciendo ahora
ante el inminente impacto para los
hogares la casa blanca y el senado
llegan a un acuerdo sobre un paquete de
estímulo de 2 billones de dólares
el 2 de abril el mundo supera el millón
de contagios
mientras china reabre la ciudad de wuhan
tras un bloqueo de 76 días
nueva york- se convierte en el nuevo
epicentro de la pandemia
los hospitales están al borde del
colapso
para el 9 de abril el mundo supera las
100.000 muertes de las cuales 14.000 se
han producido en el estado de nueva york
14 de abril donald trump rompe con la
misión
hoy le estoy dando instrucciones a mi
administración para que tenga la
financiación de la organización mundial
de la salud mientras se realiza una
revisión para evaluar su papel en el
manejo y el encubrimiento de la
propagación del corona
bring up
[Música]
el 20 de abril una serie de causas entre
ellas la pandemia genera que el petróleo
por primera vez en la historia
cotice en números negativos de nuevo el
presidente de trump hace una polémica
declaración
entonces veo que el desinfectante lo
elimina en un minuto hay alguna manera
de que puedas hacer algo así como una
inyección
en jackson ensayos
millones de musulmanes en todo el mundo
celebran desde el 23 de abril el ramadán
el mes sagrado del islám pero la gran
mezquita de la meca está vacía
d
[Música]
la economía de eeuu pierde 20.5 millones
de puestos de trabajo en abril la mayor
caída desde la gran depresión la tasa de
desempleo sube al 14.7 por ciento
mientras los casos y muertes empiezan a
disminuir en nueva york
latinoamérica preocupa a la oms brasil y
méxico encabeza en la lista de los
países más afectados y sus mandatarios
asumen polémicas posturas frente a la
pandemia después de la puñalada no será
un leve resfriado lo que me derribará
vale si el médico del ministerio de
salud recomienda un nuevo examen lo haré
de lo contrario me comportaré como
cualquiera de ustedes aquí voy de aquí
lo del coronavirus eso de que esto no se
puede uno abraza hay que abrazarse si no
pasa nada
en esta fase de la pandemia de las
imágenes más duras se ven en la ciudad
ecuatoriana de guayaquil desbordada por
los fallecimientos los cuerpos en las
calles y los ataúdes de cartón hacen que
el miedo colectivo se propague
los impactos económicos también se ven
en la región latam y avianca a las
aerolíneas más grandes de américa latina
se declaran en bancarrota el 22 de mayo
brasil supera a rusia y se convierte en
el número 2 del mundo en casos
para el 7 de junio las muertes en el
mundo superan las 400 mil y los casos
confirmados se acercan a los 7 millones
europa se prepara para el verano y la
mayoría de los países reabre
gradualmente tenemos el propósito de
garantizar la reactivación del turismo
nacional de cara a esta misma temporada
de verano
[Música]
miles de ciudadanos corren a las costas
y las imágenes de playas abarrotadas se
vuelven una constante se reactivan las
ligas de fútbol y la nueva normalidad se
vive en las calles del viejo continente
[Música]
la crisis en latinoamérica se agudiza
tres presidentes de la región tan
positivo yo sí me diagnosticado he sido
contagiado
por ejemplo si no me hubiera hecho la
prueba de kobe 19 no habría sabido el
resultado y dio positivo
y dado que en la última semana muchos de
ellos dieron positivo al coronavirus me
hice la prueba y también he dado
positivo
el 11 de julio trump usa cubrebocas en
público por primera vez durante una
visita a un hospital militar las últimas
semanas de julio varios países de
latinoamérica empiezan a relajar sus
medidas
sin embargo en europa el sol del verano
se empieza a ocultar de nuevo
con una economía golpeada y tras un
verano con relativa normalidad el virus
volvió a impactar en europa después de
una apertura en vacaciones de verano con
el frío la segunda ola llegó al
continente y aunque en algunos países
como francia y alemania- la mortalidad
subió en esta oportunidad no se vieron
las escenas caóticas del primer impacto
tras un leve respiro los casos en europa
vuelven a crecer para principios de
agosto el continente supera los 3
millones de contagios y las 200.000
muertes
las restricciones vuelven pero esta vez
ante el agotamiento de los ciudadanos se
desatan protestas ante la imposición de
nuevas medidas
las autoridades piden no bajar la
guardia
aquí en esta región y particularmente en
la zona del lille estamos viendo un
aumento de los datos de la epidemia que
debe llevarnos más que nunca a estar
extremadamente movilizados y atentos a
nuestro éxito del principio no debe
volvernos imprudentes el clima de verano
es bueno para todos pero no debe
llevarnos a ser descuidados en nuestra
lucha contra la pandemia porque podemos
ver estos días cuan incierta e inestable
es la situación no la pandemia no ha
terminado no se ha ido estamos en medio
de ella
pese a que los casos no paran de crecer
en el mundo un país de 1300 millones de
ciudadanos se convierte en el nuevo
epicentro
[Música]
un día supera a brasil y se convierte en
el segundo país con más casos de kobe 19
así que las principales conclusiones de
esta encuesta serológicas son que una de
cada 15 personas mayores de 10 años ha
estado expuesta al sars co2 la campaña
hacia las elecciones presidenciales se
reactiva en eeuu y donald trump ahora
tiene un culpable de la pandemia
mientras perseguimos a este futuro
brillante debemos responsabilizar a la
nación que desató esta plaga en el mundo
china zaira
el 27 de septiembre el mundo supera el
millón de muertes a causa de la pandemia
de kobe 19
tras un caótico debate presidencial en
que su equipo de campaña no usó
cubrebocas ni respeto a la distancia el
presidente de trump y su esposa dan
positivo
esta noche la primera dama y yo hemos
dado positivo en el test de kobe 19
comenzaremos nuestro proceso de
cuarentena y recuperación inmediata
pasaremos esto juntos
[Música]
tras una convulsa selecciones
presidenciales joe biden vence a donald
trump un resultado que algunos analistas
atribuyen a su manejo de la pandemia
el 8 de noviembre del mundo supera los
50 millones de casos y registran más de
un millón doscientas mil muertes sin
embargo un día después un rayo de
esperanza llega tras meses de malas
noticias
[Música]
pese a prácticamente haber detenido o
modificado todas nuestras actividades
sociales el virus no da tregua sin
embargo en noviembre llega una noticia
que abre un rayo de esperanza la
humanidad de desarrollar la vacuna más
rápida de su historia
tras meses de investigación la
estadounidense facer y la alemana bayón
tec anuncian que su vacuna contra el
coronavirus es eficaz en más de un 90%
la información es recibida con
beneplácito y cautela a la vez
[Música]
hemos superado un obstáculo importante
pero quedan varios antes de que sepamos
que se puede utilizar la vacuna pues ya
sois
news acabamos de recibir noticias
positivas en esta lucha con el anuncio
de que se ha avanzado hacia una vacuna
exitosa unos días después la compañía
estadounidense moderna y el instituto
ruso gama leia aseguran que sus vacunas
también tienen una eficacia de más del
90% el 20 de noviembre pzifer ibai un
tec hacen una solicitud de uso de
emergencia al regulador de salud de eeuu
el 30 de noviembre moderna anuncia que
también solicitó a los reguladores el
mismo permiso
el 2 de diciembre de reino unido se
convierte en el primer país occidental
en aprobar una vacuna la de facer y
bayonne tec unos días después una mujer
de 90 años es la primera persona en
recibir
tras meses de secretismo el presidente
ruso vladimir putin anuncia que su país
comenzará un plan masivo de inmunización
con su vacuna sputnik
les pediría que organizaran el trabajo
para que a fines de la próxima semana
hayamos comenzado esta vacunación a gran
escala pero ante el optimismo
generalizado la o ms hizo una
advertencia roberson vaccines gibbs a
soul lift el progreso en las vacunas nos
da a todos un impulso y ahora podemos
empezar a ver la luz al final del túnel
sin embargo a la o ms le preocupa que
haya una percepción cada vez mayor de
que la pandemia ha terminado en este
punto la preocupación ya no es la vacuna
en sí misma sino el acceso para los
países en vías de desarrollo la
esperanza para estas naciones ahora está
puesta en kóvacs una iniciativa
internacional que busca una distribución
equitativa
[Música]
en repetidas ocasiones he pedido que la
vacuna kobe 19 sea un bien público
mundial disponible para todos en todas
partes el acelerador act y su iniciativa
kóvacs son las herramientas para
llevarnos allí el 12 de diciembre el
regulador de alimentos y fármacos de
eeuu da su visto bueno para el uso de
emergencia
la vacuna de facer by on dec dos días
después una enfermera en nueva york
sería la primera inmunizada
en los días posteriores varios países de
américa latina comienzan con sus planes
de vacunación ecuador y chile son los
primeros en aprobar el proyecto de facer
y beyond tech
el 19 de diciembre la fed aprueba el uso
de la vacuna de moderna y ese mismo día
el vicepresidente saliente mike pence se
inocula la de facer
[Música]
el 21 de diciembre la comisión europea
da su aval al proyecto de facer beyond
tech y ese mismo día es el presidente
electo de eeuu joe biden quien se vacuna
a la inmunización podrá comenzar a la
misma hora en toda la unión europea el
27 28 y 29 de diciembre esta es una muy
buena manera de terminar este año
difícil y finalmente comenzará a pasar
la página sobre el hobbit 19 finalistas
la vacuna ha llenado de esperanzas al
mundo pero la pandemia mostró aún más
las notorias e inmensas desigualdades de
nuestras sociedades en la carrera por la
vacuna de los países ricos se han
asegurado cientos de millones de dosis
para sus poblaciones y muy lejos se ve
la posibilidad de inmunizarse para las
naciones más pobres
[Música]
el 2020 determina con un rayo de
esperanza pero también con grandes
preocupaciones las autoridades
sanitarias temen que los países menos
desarrollados no tengan un acceso
oportuno a las vacunas y que el
acaparamiento de esta se genere una
inequidad mayor gracias por habernos
acompañado por este recorrido por un año
en el que literalmente una pandemia
conmocionó el mundo recuerden que si
quieren volver a ver este especial
pueden hacerlo en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
nos vemos próximamente
[Música]